[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour ce
dernier numéro de l'année 2010 est dédié
à vos idées sorties durant les vacances
de noël tout de suite
le sommaire pacman tetris ou pondre des
jeux vidéo qui ont marqué des
générations ils reviennent dans une
exposition ludique et interactive aux
clayes-sous-bois des consoles mythiques
à découvrir ou redécouvrir le retro
gaming a investi l'espace philippe
noiret sa responsable nous en parlera
vialette et petit pot de beurre venez
vivre les courses de noël en famille au
petit moulin des vaux de cernay
un spectacle interprété par la conteuse
caroline jigging durant les vacances et
les vacances c'est aussi l'occasion de
laisser libre cours à sa créativité la
mise à triolet aragon propose de
réaliser sa propre sous la neige dans
notre rendez-vous junior mais la nuit
nous expliquera ses ateliers
mais avant les jeux vidéo est tout seul
à la télévision tout un symbole pour des
générations celle de nos parents ou de
nos grands parents qui ont connu la télé
à tube cathodique l'arrivée de la
couleur ou les premiers pas de l'homme
sur la lune à saint quentin en yvelines
une exposition au musée de la ville
permet de redécouvrir cette époque et
questionne sur notre rapport à la
télévision aujourd'hui les 27 décembre
et 5 janvier des ateliers sont proposés
aux enfants à partir de 7 ans un stage
pour créer un journal télévisé et
devenir reporter le temps d'un après
midi le directeur du mou du musée de la
ville nous a parlé de cette exposition
c'est tout laventure de la télévision
qui est retracée
il ya notamment l'aspect technique qui
est
abordée en guise d'introduction mais le
propos de l'exposition tourne davantage
autour du spectateur et la manière dont
cette petite lucarne le petit écran a
influencé nos intérieurs nos modes de
vie et notre rapport à cet objet au
cours de son évolution qu'on suit
globalement de son invention et plus
particulièrement après après la deuxième
guerre mondiale jusqu'au début du 20e
siècle et jusqu'au 1er janvier venez
patiner en famille aux clayes-sous-bois
pour la deuxième année la patinoire de
noël a été installé sur le parvis de
l'espace philippe noiret
les plus petits pourront s'initier à
l'aide de chariots elle est ouverte tous
les jours toute la journée mais
seulement l'après midi pour les 24 25 31
décembre et 1er janvier
et on reste aux clayes-sous-bois avec
notre invité pour parler jeux vidéo
cette fois que vous ayez 6 ou 60 ans les
jeux vidéo vous en avez forcément au
moins entendu parler si vous n'y avez
pas vous même jouer l espace philippe
noiret une exposition retrace le jeu
vidéo à travers le temps atari nes super
nes des noms exotiques pour les jeunes
oreilles mais bien connue des plus
grands christelle bidoire la responsable
de l'espace fit noiret est avec nous
bonjour alors durant les vacances de
noël vous avez décidé de consacrer votre
structure ou rétro et demi exactement
c'est un retour sur l'histoire du jeu
vidéo une exposition qu'on peut vivre en
famille et c'est vrai que les vacances
de noël se prête bien à cézac ce type
d'activités familiales
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir ou
redécouvrir à redécouvrir pour les
jeunes générations et les parents
les papas les mamans vont pouvoir
montrer ce sur quoi ils jouent eux dans
les années 70 les années 80 on retrouve
des jeux individuels
dans ce format de poche aussi des jeux
des jeux de table des consoles voilà
tout ce qui a pu faire l'enfance des
plus des plus âgés et donc vous le
disiez c'est vraiment en famille les
parents pour pouvoir expliquer aussi aux
enfants oui on peut manipuler
oui bien sûr les les consoles sont en
accès pour les familles donc ça permet
aussi de voir l'évolution des pratiques
on voit les premières consoles avec deux
manettes puis 4 ça montre l'évolution du
jeu et de la pratique on peut en avoir
ou on passe à une pratique individuelle
à une pratique plus conviviales comme je
le disais en famille entre amis donc des
consoles sont à l'accès à l'accès du
public pour pouvoir jouer ensemble
partager un moment entre générations ou
à l'intérieur même des générations alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme je souhaitais
pas que manet tetris tout à l'heure on
retrouve le fameux donc et qu'on les
premiers mario aussi il ya des on a des
jeux individuels comme je disais des
consoles on a aussi des bandes d'arcade
qui permet d'explorer assis face à face
à son écran à lutter avec batman spider
man ou autre et puis on est aussi
d'étape cocktail qui permet de jouer en
face à face sont des tables comme des
tables basses avec des jeux vidéo
intégré le bonheur de la table basse
alors comment se construit l'exposition
c'est un circuit spécial à suivre on est
vraiment un peuple ingrat vite entre
différents univers oui c'est réparti
vous avez tout un espace justement
console télé on peut jouer on peut jouer
à plusieurs
des vitrines où sont exposés les
premières les premières game boy qu'on a
pu avoir en noir et blanc
on a aussi des espaces salons justement
avec les fameuses tables cocktails et
avoue pouvait glaner voilà d'aller des
spas sont espacées au choix en fait hier
juste un peu exactement alors c'est une
exposition qui s'adresse surtout aux
nostalgiques ou alors au contraire
l'idée c'est vraiment de montrer
l'évolution aux plus jeunes transmettre
les indépendantes il s'est heurté à fait
ça dd de partager un moment de jeu et le
jeu s'est jamais sait jamais un regard
quand il s'agit de jouer on n'est jamais
un gars vrai que c'est un domaine qui
parle à toutes les générations
exactement alors comment vous est venue
l'idée de créer cette exposition et
comment ce que vous avez trouvé tout ce
qui fonctionne et on a la chance de
travailler avec une association manier
loisirs qui une association de
passionnés vraiment de collectionneurs
qui ont amassé sur plusieurs années tout
un tas de jeux on avait déjà travaillé
avec eux l'année dernière sur une
exposition de flipper est aussi l'année
d'avant sur une exposition géants jeux
jouets anciens
c'est une mine d'or de cette association
on travaille régulièrement avec eux donc
c'est grâce à vous avez plus exactement
on a pu mettre en place cette belle
exposition y en a combien alors du coup
des jeunes à redécouvrir impôts c'est
une question piège il y en a beaucoup
vous n'avez vous pas le bronx à venir
voir merci bon compte que christelle
bidon est revenu sur notre plateau donc
on le rappelle leurs vidéos pacage
l'exposition consacrée aux radios
guillot aurait aux radios au rétro
gaming
avis aux joueurs avertis ou aux curieux
elle est à visiter jusqu'au 10 janvier à
l'espace philippe noiret merci beaucoup
christelle du doigt adrien theaux
camille galette et petit pot de beurre
les courses de noël prennent leur quête
leurs quartiers au petit moulin des vaux
de cernay une heure en compagnie de la
conteuse caroline julie nicolas landry a
embarqué pour ce voyage féerie de noël
ils ont donné une grosse galère
bien doré bien croustillantes et lui ont
dit comme ça c'est un petit creux au
milieu de la forêt tu pourras toujours
te régaler en campagne c'est l'histoire
d'un joueur de violon partis au village
pour rentrer chez lui il doit passer par
une forêt un bois route des ennemis
inquiétant il avoue fait un nom il en
était sûr ils entendaient est brune
branches cassées derrière lui de bruyne
froissé je raconte les grandes questions
universelles et intemporelles donc les
peurs les joies les surprises des
impatiences et la vie de tous les jours
c'est la vie des hommes depuis des
milliers d'années finalement on compte
depuis toujours offert à mesure des
débats et des mots en fait on apprend
quantité de choses voilà les comptes
aide à grandir à sourire
alors on apprend un voyage à travers
différentes histoires drôles ou
poétiques la féerie de noël opère chez
les petits comme chez les plus grands
d'âgés mais parce que c'était
intéressant de savoir
j'ai un prêt d'urgence enfin c'était
drôle et tout lorsque on parle du loup
justement à cet âge là ils ont souvent
un petit peu cette crainte du loup et le
fait qu' on désacralise un petit peu
voilà le loup ça permet de rendre cette
peur un petit peu moins en moins
présente les enfants dès 4 ans sont
attendus pour venir rêver au petit
moulin des vaux de cernay
réservation obligatoire pour embarquer
avec caroline dans son monde enchanté
c'est un loup qui avait là midi
[Musique]
et on retrouve mélanie pour notre
rendez-vous junior bonjour mais dani
jarque avait alors où nous emmener vous
pour cette toute dernière chronique de
l'année 2010 je vous propose qu'on fasse
un saut dans le temps on part tout de
suite en 2018 à la maison elsa triolet
et luis aragon où les petites mains des
enfants vont être mises à contribution
pour vivre un noël en miniature et
découvrir aussi les trésors qui se cache
au coeur du parc de 5 ha un parc où se
trouve une exposition permanente de
sculptures donnés par des artistes amis
du lieu qui ont exposé aussi dans la
maison et ce sont ces sculptures qui
sont au coeur du opposé au mois de
janvier coûte
les enfants sont invités à capturer
l'une des sculptures du jardin de
sculptures de la maison dans une boule à
neige
l'idée c'était de les familiariser avec
l'art contemporain mais de façon ludique
et en lien avec la thématique des fêtes
de noël fêtes de fin d'année alors c'est
une activité avec de la pâte fimo il ya
une trentaine de sculptures dans le parc
les enfants vont pouvoir choisir celles
qu'ils veulent alors ils ont surtout le
choix entre quatre cultures différentes
à l'image on va en voir deux la première
est plutôt de l'art abstrait on dirait
un grand stylo rouge poté dans le sol
elle est l'oeuvre de kenji wimax ou un
sculpteur et dessinateur japonais
la deuxième s'inspire elle du football
elle est signée françois qu on a un
joueur de baby foot donc un jouet mais
qui va être représentée en argenté dans
une couleur qui va plutôt évoqué l'
idole guildhall païenne
donc l'idée ça va être d'exprimer le
fait que les joueurs de foot sont un
petit peu les nouveaux dieux mais qui
peuvent aussi tomber très vite de leur
piédestal donc c'est un peu cette
ambivalence du fait que les joueurs de
foot on est gens qu'on adore détester
l'artiste a traduit par cette oeuvre
alors les activités ont lieu les 3 et 4
janvier prochain de 15h à 17h30 elle
s'adresse aux enfants de 4 à 12 ans
attention ce sont les vacances alors la
maison triolet aragon est fermée pour
s'inscrire c'est grâce aux mails qui
s'affichent au bas de l'écran précisons
bien sûr le nom le prénom et l'âge de
l'enfant ainsi que la date choisie et je
voulais profiter qu ami de cette
dernière émission de l'année
petit clin d'oeil chaque semaine vous
m'invitez sur ce plateau pour proposer
des idées sorties ou des activités
manuelles alors ça c'est le devant du
décor que nos téléspectateurs peuvent
voir mais vous ne connaissez pas les
coulisses de ce plateau nous choisissons
ses chroniques ensemble et puisque ça
vous êtes très régulièrement derrière la
caméra
image je vous propose de remonter à
septembre les juniors mon but a testé
l'accrobranche de l'île de loisirs saint
quentin en yvelines moi j'ai testé et
parfois subi vous avez aussi donné de
votre personne au regard de la suite
m
[Musique]
les
diablement l'a16 vous êtes très haut oui
effectivement un grand moment ce
tournage j'étais ravi nous accompagner
en tout cas pour cette année 2010 est
donc encore beaucoup de choses hein pour
2018 merci en tout cas mais l'ennemi on
espère aussi qu'à la rentrée vous nous
ferez une jolie aux boules à neige à
leur rang avec les ateliers à la
machette rio l'arago ya plein de plein
d'autres choses et qu'ils réfléchissent
merci beaucoup en tout cas mélanie c'est
bientôt la fin de notre émission mais
avant de nous quitter sachez que le zoo
de thoiry sera ouverte tous les jours
pendant ses vacances de noël fermeture
seulement le 25 décembre et le 1er
janvier et pour coller la magie de ces
fêtes des comptes seront proposés
gratuitement tous les jours de 15 heures
à 16 heures le service loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous terminons l'année 2010 est
sûre ce numéro mais on se retrouve en
2018 pour une nouvelle année pleine
d'idées sorties de divertissement en
famille rendez vous le 5 janvier pour
notre prochain numéro je vous souhaite
de bonnes vacances de très belles fêtes
de fin d'année
m
oh